nicole first of all that top you're
wearing right now
be brave be bold there's a reason why
you're wearing that
yes why did you choose it well my mom
actually picked it out for me and i was
going to take it with me on the show and
maybe i should have but i think like
just going back on the show as a winner
for the third time that took
guts so yeah being bold um
and not being scared and so yeah that's
kind of why i wore it
one of the things is we get to a chance
to talk to you right after the finale
but it's been a few days you've been
home now
what is the aftermath for you after big
brother and
being reunited with your fiance it's
been so wonderful being reunited with
victor and my family
um it's nice to be surrounded by people
that love you and are not trying to
manipulate you
so um i i just like i'm loving
every second of it and uh i'm really
glad that i had
victor come out to california right
after
because usually after the finale you do
have loved ones and this was like
different with the pandemic so um i
think i got
it as good it was as good as it could be
with the circumstances
yeah now that you've got to sit down
with the idea what happened on the
finale i mean that was a big shocker we
saw your reaction all of us were shocked
by what happened uh have you
i guess do you understand it now why he
cody made that choice
i do understand it i just think that he
could have i would have been fine with
knowing whoever wins let's just take
enzo because that's something that was
on my mind and on my heart as well
and i think just his charade up to the
finale
and constantly trying to make me feel
guilty for considering taking enzo is
what kind of
hurts me because yeah um that was a
little bit
because we were close enough to where i
think i would have handled it finance
like hey i can't beat you hey i can't
beat you either let's just take enzo
but it was never it was never like that
and so i think that's why the shot comes
um so much have you talked to him since
then and
is he invited to your wedding and are
you guys good
i haven't talked to him um i haven't
talked to him i think that we're both
just trying to get into
the groove of things again and i
understand that and so
um i don't know i i don't hold like
it was a game move i get it it was
strategic it was smart
um i think i would feel better about it
if he owned it as a strategic move
rather than i think in some interviews
he was just like well i loved enzo
moore and so that's what's a little bit
confusing to me is like
okay if it's just literally based on
personal feelings that's fine i just
i just would rather i think it was a
game move
and so i'd
that i have to like catch up on there's
so much to do
in a month it's been like that's crazy
kudos to you i don't know how you're
gonna do it but i know you can do it
how are you doing mentally now that
you're out and you're kind of learning
about
some of the subject people have been
talking about big brother this year
um i think it's a lot to take in and i
think i was really taken aback by
a lot of it and so um i'm doing what i
need to do
mentally to move
forward and apologize to people that
need
that i need to apologize to and have
conversations with people i need to have
conversations with
and i think doing it um one-on-one and
is the best best for me i've never been
one to really
put i put my life out there a little bit
but i don't really
i've always been a private person as
i'm handling that handling like life and
so
um it's a it's just it's been a lot for
sure and i'm really happy that i have my
you know loved ones to help me navigate
it
i have talked to ian one on one we had a
very positive conversation yesterday
i had apologized and um it was accepted
i apologize to anyone who
that that has hurt and
i'm still trying to navigate
the understand the whole situation
and as far as what i'm worried about i'm
worried about
mine and ian's relationship and making
sure that he
understands what understands the whole
thing and for me it's just like
i was shocked coming out to that
thinking that that's something that was
viewed as how it was viewed and so i'm
still reflecting and learning
and um my number one priority right now
is
ian and like i said i talked to him and
um and that's what i'm focused on
is is ian how has big brother been for
you this year
in terms of all-stars and experiences he
had before would you say this was one of
the better ones
or no um
this was not a no it was not a
positive experience that's for sure
now you're going to focus on your
wedding yeah
on your family um would you ever do it
again
no no no
nicole we've learned a lot from you so i
have to say i appreciate
all your time on the show and it has
caused
a lot of conversations that are needed
during this time and
i appreciate you and i appreciate your
honesty
and your honest because it's going to
help a lot of people so thank you very
much
wishing you all the best thank you
you